hello welcome to the NewsHour we begin
in Israel where doctors and medical
workers have gone on strike to protest
against government changes to the
judicial system the doctors were
authorized by Israel's labor Court to
walk off the job for only two hours at a
time Israel's largest Union which
represents more than 800 000 workers is
discussing a nationwide general strike
the industrial action follows
legislation passed by parliament on
Monday which limits the authority of
Supreme Court judges to strike down
government decisions
now a violent protests broke out on the
streets in a number of cities horse
Mounted Police tried to break up
protests in Tel Aviv and a settler from
the occupied West Bank rammed into
protesters on a freeway in the southern
Sharon region The Driver injured a
number of people as his car caught fire
protesters are angry because they say
the bill will damage Israel's democracy
Let's cross over to Ben and Smith our
correspondent who's in the capital Tel
Aviv standing by Bernard this is sort of
the day after the vote protesters really
failed to stop the bill will they
continue is there anything really worth
protesting about anymore
so yes calm on Israel's streets but the
anger of those opposed to the digital
reforms is still very much there still
very fresh and many people who've been
taking part in the protest over the last
six months yes
it hasn't got them anywhere because
Netanyahu has launched the process past
the first day first first one of these
judicial reform bills but people who've
been on the process will say well look
we delayed it for six months and we
managed to Galvanize very disparate
parts of society around one issue we
should still keep the pressure on there
will be appeals against this legislation
appeals to the very Court whose powers
are being powers are being curtailed by
this new law but there is a particular
concern about military Readiness and a
concern from the Israel's Institute for
National Security studies warning that
the government's judicial reforms could
lead to the complete collapse of the
Reserve System that's particular worry
about Pilots Reserve Pilots voluntary
Reserve pilots who have to keep up
training to be ready to fly at a
moment's notice they've said if this law
goes through and it has they will not be
available for Duty so while the
government will never of course admit
that the military is not ready publicly
there are concerns Burns is under there
are concerns that the military's
Readiness to react quickly could be
affected by the progression of this bill
and by the determination of this
government to push it through the right
wing side of the cabinet will certainly
be buoyant at this result I mean they
will want to push forward perhaps more
policies through and really put the
pressure on Netanyahu and it really the
book stops with him doesn't it as the
prime minister to agree to all of this
well if you already want an indication
of the sort of corner that Netanyahu has
painted himself into and this Hostage to
fortune that has become with the
far-right Coalition Partners the ultra
Orthodox party and now wants to put
forward a bill that will make it the law
that those who study the Torah these are
heredity ultra-orthodox men instead of
doing military service that will be
considered equivalent to military
service now they already don't do
military service but if you are in the
military you get all sorts of tax breaks
and benefits grants for Education this
sort of thing it's enormously as a big
frustration amongst the majority of
Israeli population they all throw
Orthodox don't do military service
already that but they want to push this
bill through again the Supreme Court
previously has stopped to this bill but
because the Supreme Court's powers are
being curtailed it may not be as easy
next time now netanyahu's liquid party
says this is never going to become law
but it's an indication of the sort of
bills that are on the agenda of the
far-right parties in this government
there for us in Tel Aviv thank you
well on an official visit to Qatar the
United Kingdom's foreign secretary James
cleverley told Al Jazeera Israel needs
to protect the independence of its
judiciary
we have a very close relationship with
Israel and that strength of relationship
means that we can speak directly and
frankly with the government of Israel
what of course we feel is that
constitutional decisions should be for
the country to make but we want to make
sure that Israel protects the
independence of its Judiciary I think
that is a very important element and
something which Israel has historically
been very proud of we want to ensure
that there is as wide as wider a
coalition of support for any changes as
possible and so the government should
take action that brings people together
rather than
potentially creates Division and of
course in any system any institution you
need checks and balances and so these
are the these are the things that we
would say to our
interlocutors in the Israel government
and we join with other countries around
the world wishing Israel's success and
peace and prosperity but also making
sure that they have a robust and
independent judiciary